- When creating business presentations,
it easily happens that the slides
that you come up with
look like walls of text.
When everything you write
might be perfectly fine and correct,
just the look of it is boring,
it's not interesting.
And for sure, this is not what you want
for your professional presentations.
So when I worked at McKinsey,
we often like to talk about
the look and feel of a slide.
So independent of the content,
what is the look and feel
of what you are creating?
So in today's video,
I am talking about how you can improve
the look and feel of your
presentation documents
by using icons.
So welcome to another coffee break
here on my channel, Firm Learning.
My name is Heinrich
and here on my channel,
I want to help you to become successful
in the first years of your career.
I wanna start by saying
thank you to Simple Slides,
the sponsor of today's video.
Simple Slides is a service
offering slide templates and infographics,
I use the service myself
and can very much recommended it
but more about that later in the video.
So thank you for joining
me in today's video,
grab yourself a cup of coffee, as always.
Today I'm just sticking to my water
because it's already quite late in Germany
but I hope that you are
having a great time.
So let's now look into a situation
which I'm facing pretty
much every single day.
And this is, I have a page like this,
so this is a typical text
page, in this example,
there is a company who
looks into expanding
into new geographies and new sectors,
and are over here you're summarizing
all the opportunities that
this company might have.
So for instance, geographic
expansion to new countries
or sector expansion into new sectors.
Now while all of this might
be completely accurate,
what I write here,
somehow this page seems kind of dull,
it seems kind of boring,
it's pretty much just a wall of text.
And while it's okay to
have some pages like that
in your document,
you do wanna make sure that
not every page looks like this.
And indeed, a simple way that you can do
to improve the look and
feel of a slide like this
is to use some icons, to
add some icons to your page.
And if you work for a
large consulting firm,
probably you have libraries of icons,
libraries of little
infographics to your disposal
that you can use.
But now for the average Joe,
and probably also for somebody not working
in these typical consulting firms,
the access to these
kind of slide libraries
is much more restricted,
most companies just do not
have something like this
off the shelf.
Now of course, what you
can do is to go on Google
and Google for some icons
there in the picture search.
But here of course, the issue
is that most of the material
is copyright protected,
so you cannot just use it
for professional context
and you just don't wanna use it
in your business presentations,
even if you're an employee,
because otherwise you might risk
that your employer gets
into serious trouble
if you use these copyright
protected pictures.
So thankfully, there is a service
that I also use myself
for my presentations,
and this service is called Simple Slides.
Simple Slides is a
library of slide templates
and infographics that
are at your disposal,
and if you get Simple Slides,
you can use all the material
for whatever application you want.
So for business and
commercial purposes, as well.
They've over 10,000
slides and infographics
at your disposal
and the library is
constantly being updated.
Also it doesn't matter
what software you use,
so whether you use PowerPoint,
Google Slides or Keynote,
they have material for all
these software packages,
so you should be covered in either way.
Simple Slides offers
three different tiers.
Personally I have the premium access,
which gives me access to
all of their materials
and all of future updates as well.
And yes, this is a lifetime access,
so for a one off payment,
you can use it your whole life.
This is how it looks like on the back end
once you've opened an account.
And then here on access slides
you have access to the search bar,
where you can look for whatever you want.
So if we type in strategy,
you get different results for that,
if we type in marketing,
you get different results for that.
And all of these are search results
leading to slide packages
where then you can access
many different infographics and slides
that fit the individual theme.
But now I am looking for icons
because I wanna add some icons
to the PowerPoint presentation.
So let's search for icons,
and you can directly see
that several search results
are popping up,
so let's just start by
looking into the vector icons,
and here they now offer a package
of all kinds of vector icons
that you can use for your presentation.
So if we now download here
the PowerPoint version,
it pretty much looks like this.
Now I have opened it here for you guys,
this is now the package that you get.
So about 14 pages full
of different icon sets
that you can use for your presentation,
including also some world
maps, which you can use
and then also use individual
countries out of it.
So let's now go back and prepare the page
for adding some icons.
So I'm duplicating the page.
Now let's first make some space.
Our goal is to add the
icons to the left here.
So let's make this a little bit smaller.
Let's move this to the right
and now we have some space
to add some icons here to the left.
So first we have your two
countries, Germany and France,
and here of course,
now it would make sense
to get some country icons.
So here now you can click
in and select Germany
to then get the icon for Germany.
Now it's of course pretty great.
So let's color it in such a nice dark blue
and we have the first one.
Now let's add the equivalent for France.
Let's insert it this way, color it,
now we have an icon for France,
let's make this a little
bit smaller, maybe.
Now it looks good to me,
let's properly align it, very nice.
Now data analysis.
So let's just look for what we
could use for data analysis,
probably something like
this makes a lot of sense.
Let's color it as well.
Now for express services,
probably something like a delivery service
or parcels or something like that.
This one here looks good to me,
let's insert it as well, let's color it.
And probably now also another advantage
of these types of
infographics that you see here
is that they are vector graphics.
So this means that it doesn't
matter how big they are,
whatever the sizes that you need,
they will never look out
of resolution, right,
because the resolution
automatically scales,
which is of course very comfortable
when working with them in different sizes.
Let's make this smaller now, here we go.
And let's now add this
to the page as well.
Next mining services,
so probably something with
workshop tools would look nice,
for instance, something like this.
Let's add it, let's
color it, let's insert it
and here we go.
So now we have it,
we have icons included in the page
and I hope that you agree
that now this looks a
bit more interesting,
it's a bit nicer to look at,
the whole presentation looks a
bit less dull if you do this.
So generally, whenever you
have some distinct elements
of your page that you talk about,
distinct buckets of things,
this is usually always an opportunity
to include some icons
to make it a little bit
more visually stimulating.
What you should avoid, though,
what I see some people do,
is to only show the icons
without the explaining text.
So pretty much do something like this,
just here the text and the icons.
This is something I
cannot recommend you to do
because the problem is that
icons often are not that self explanatory.
It often takes quite some
time and mental energy
to interpret what exactly
this or this or this means
and easily different people
will have different opinions on that.
There are only very few icons
which are universally
and interculturally
accepted and recognized.
To use this very carefully,
use icons only to add to an existing name
but do not only rely
on the power of icons.
So when should you and when
should you not use icons
in your professional
business presentations?
My general recommendation
would be to use them
but to use them sparsely.
So often a good way to use them
is if you have some
elements, some opportunities,
some levers, some other buckets of things
you have in your presentation
that repeat through all
throughout the slide deck.
Because this way you
can establish some icons
in the beginning on some structure pages
and to help the reader
to make some connections
among the different pages
due to the repeating icons that you use.
So applications like this, in my opinion,
make a lot of sense
because they improve the
look and feel of the pages
and they also have a valuable
benefit for the reader.
What you should avoid
is completely spamming your
presentation with icons.
Of course in these business presentations
on almost every page, you
will have an opportunity
to, in theory, add a
couple of icons to them.
But if you add icons to everything,
they just become meaningless
and at some point it also
looks very repetitive
and also to some extent unprofessional
and childish if you do that.
Try to convey meaning via the icons,
try to use them as a true
value add for the reader.
This is the sweet spot
that you should really look out for
when using icons in your presentations.
I hope this was insightful.
If you have any questions,
leave me a comment below
in the comment section
and I will do my very best
to answer every single one.
If you want to learn
more about Simple Slides,
I added a link to their servers
below in the video description.
There you can sign up,
what I also very much
like about this service is
that it's not one of these
monthly subscriptions
where you end up paying for it forever,
but it's rather a one time fee.
So if you took any value
out of this video at all,
please hit the like button
for the YouTube algorithm
and also subscribe to my
channel for regular updates.
If you want to see even more from me,
I also have an Instagram
channel with even more content,
my Instagram handle is
firmlearning as well,
and I also have an email list,
there is a sign up link to that
in the video description as well.
I now wanna take a moment
to thank all the members
of this channel, Firm Learning.
Thank you so much, thank
you for your support.
Without you all of this
would not be possible
and if you wanna become a member as well
and also benefit from
some member only perks,
there is a Join button next
to the subscribe button below.
If you hit it you get all the details,
what it means, what all your benefits are
and what you need to do.
So thank you so much for your time,
very much appreciated.
Looking forward to next week's video
as every week I will release
a new video next Saturday,
so until then, have a
good weekend and bye bye.